INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
So today, we are going to walk
through how to actually use
Elastic Bock Store, so EBS.
We've kind of done it with the--
just launching EC2
instances and having
that sitting on the back end.
But we actually
haven't done it where
we've explicitly, separately
created an EBS volume
and then mounted it
to our EC2 instance.
Reason we'd want to do that
really is because there might
be situations where, first
off, we want to pass off a EBS
volume to another user
or another instance
that we've created.
Or if you have a
snapshot that you
want to create of
your volume, and you
want to back up, and then
overwrite your existings
volume with that snapshot.
All these kind of
things are done really
by explicitly creating
those volumes.
And so I just want to
walk you through once
kind of how we do that.
I'm going to start by actually
just creating a instance,
and I'm just launching an EC2
instance here, just the same
as we did in the first demo.
EBSLabDemo.
That's what we're
going to name it.
We'll just do Ubuntu.
And then let's do 20.04.
Leave all that the same.
And you'll notice
here that I'm just
going to use my demo key pair.
It's the same key pair
that I used when I had--
or when I did the first demo.
You can reuse them.
It's perfectly OK to
reuse your key pairs.
Just know that there
is an extra security
risk if you-- technically
because you have
or if somebody has access
to your secret key,
then they can access
every instance that
utilizes that same secret key.
But none of these
instances that I'm creating
have any access to
do anything really,
so it's not super critical.
So here you'll see
that I'm leaving, first
off, the security group,
everything default.
We're just going to kind of do
a basic security group here.
And then under the storage,
this is an EBS volume,
but this is kind of
the default boot volume
that we've always been using.
So we're going to leave
that the same for now,
and just launch the instance.
And then we will come over here
and open that in a new tab.
And then I'm going to
click this little dropdown
menu on the left side over here,
go down to Elastic Block Store
and click volumes.
And then now I'm actually
going to explicitly create
a volume over here.
So just click create
volume to do that.
We're going to leave it
as gp2, but we're just
going to set it to 1 gigabyte.
We don't need anything
large for this.
An important thing
to note, though,
is we need to make sure the
availability zone of our volume
matches the availability
zone of our instance, right?
It's the same thing as
putting-- making sure that the--
when we go to try to
plug-in our hard drive,
we're actually at the location
where our computer is located.
So I'm going to come here, and
I'll see that this is actually
in US West 2C.
So I'm going to set that
to US West 2C here as well.
I'm also going to add a tag.
You don't have to
add a tag here,
but this is basically just
a way to make it searchable,
a little bit more
well documented.
I'm giving it a tag to basically
say its name is my volume.
That way I can always
see that-- and we'll
see it here in a
second that that's
how we identify it among
the list of other volumes
that are on the list
of volumes because you
might have a lot of them.
Again, everything
here is kind of
made to look a little bit
easier just because it's not
what a real organization
is, but a real organization,
if you actually
had access to it,
you might see hundreds
of different EBS volumes
here, right?
If every employee has one
or something like that,
it could just be
a super long list.
So by giving it the
tag name, first off,
it's going to populate
in that name column,
and then my volume
will show up there.
And so I ever
needed to find it, I
could just start typing my
volume and filter it to that one
directly.
OK.
So now what we're
going to do is we're
going to connect to our EC2
instance once it's live.
Let's make sure.
There we go.
So we'll go connect.
Come over to SSH client.
I'll copy that.
And then let me pull
up my terminal here.
I'll clear out the window.
And first, let's go home.
And remember, this is
on my local computer.
This is my MacBook Pro
here on premise, right?
And then first
thing I need to do
is cd to the location
where my SSH key--
or where secret key is, which is
stored in the downloads folder
still because I've not moved it.
Been lazy about that.
Make sure you move it to
somewhere that's more secure.
It doesn't accidentally get
deleted or something like that.
But for now, it's in
the downloads folder.
Probably will stay that way
for the rest of the semester.
Perfect.
So just connecting now.
So now you see I am on
the EC2 instance now.
And so first thing
we can do here--
let me actually-- oops.
I dropped my terminal
window out the way.
Bring that back up for a second.
All right.
So the first thing you can
do here is just do df-h.
Remember, that's just to look at
the disk space, how much space
is available on disk.
And you'll see that this is our
8 gigabyte boot storage, right?
That's that GP2 volume we had
kind of created in the process
of creating the EC2 instance.
But you'll notice we don't
have the 1 gigabyte one that we
actually just created
separately, that 1 gigabyte,
my volume that we created.
And so we still
need to find that.
And so first thing we can do--
or we still need to mount that.
That's the word we're looking--
we need to mount that.
So I could run this command.
And this shows me what volumes
are available to mount.
And so what I'm
looking for here--
OK.
No, that's not it there.
Not actually immediately seeing.
Oh, I know why.
I didn't actually
attach it to my volume.
So let's go back to this
menu here for a second.
And under actions--
oh, actually, no.
We'll go back here.
I think we can do it from here.
We can just click that, actions.
So yeah, I just selected this
here in the little checkbox,
actions there, attach
volume, and now
I need to actually attach
it to my instance first.
So this is me plugging
it into the instance now.
And so the device name is sdf.
Note that it may be renamed
to xvdf or even xvdp.
So-- or xvdf probably
because I think it's sdf.
So either way, we'll go
to create volume now.
And we'll just keep
an eye out for that.
And we give it a second here
to do that because it's not
an instantaneous process.
We want to see basically--
OK, so it's saying it's in
use and attached to that.
So we should be OK.
Let's check here now
on our terminal window.
And there it is right
there, xvdf, right?
So that's the device we want
to mount now to our system.
So the first thing we
can do is to check its--
that it has a file system.
So this is-- it's kind of hard
to explain without getting
too deep into it.
But basically what
we're saying is
when we attach an EBS
volume to an instance,
it's just kind of raw storage.
It doesn't actually have
any sort of structure,
any sort of software to handle
the file systems or managing
files on there.
And so we kind of need
to add that to it.
And so in our case, it
just says data, which
means it doesn't have any file.
It's just kind of raw
storage still at this point.
So we need to make a
file system for it.
And so here, we're just going
to do the ext3 file system.
So first off, we need
to do the sudo, which
is, again, super user do.
So it allows me to do things
that typically wouldn't
be allowed of a base user.
We're going to do
make file system.
And the reason I'm not
explaining this super
thoroughly is because
it's not super critical.
You're not going to
do this-- you're not
going to do a lot
of things with this
to start with, outside of
maybe mounting a volume.
So we're fine just doing that.
So now you see that it should
be creating this system here.
And now let's check-- let's
run this command from before
and see what we get.
And so now you see how
we run that sudo file.
Oh, and also, I don't know
if I've ever taught you
that you can tap up to go
through your history things
you've ran before
on this computer--
--or on this
terminal so you don't
have to actually retype things
if you're rerunning them.
But now you see, it does
have a file system on it,
so it can be used
as a file store.
So now it's actually--
it's going to be located--
or first, I actually need
to create a directory
for mounting the storage.
So I'm going to
do make directory.
And I'm going to do it
under the mount directory.
It's a common place to do it.
And so now there exists a
directory called data store,
and that is exactly where I
want to mount the volume to.
So again, if we think about
the steps we've done so far,
we've attached the
volume to our instance.
We've created a file
system on the new volume.
Now we've created a directory
to mount the new storage volume,
and now we're actually going to
mount-- oops-- mount the storage
volume.
So we're going to do dev--
oops-- xvdf, and then
we're going to go space,
and we're saying we're going
to mount it to the location,
mount data/store.
And so that now
means that we have
our data storage or
our new volume attached
mounted to that location.
And also, now we don't
want to, every time
we reboot or start
up this instance,
to have to kind
of relaunch the--
or redo this whole
process, right?
We don't have to remount it
every single time we do it.
And so we can do something
to actually force
it to remount every time.
And so we'll do
this by typing echo.
And now we're
giving it a command.
So we're basically
adding this command
to what happens at launch.
We're going to say we're
going to mount data store ext3
defaults.noatime--
oops-- 1, 2 sudo tee -a.
And I did not come up with this
code off the top of my brain.
It's definitely
going to be something
that you're going to look
up when you do at the time.
The good thing is,
is this is directly
in the documentation of Amazon.
You can just search
attach an EBS volume,
and you'll get these codes.
I mean, here.
I'll just show you.
Let's say we wanted to do--
we didn't know how to do this.
Let's say we wanted to do attach
boom, ebs volume to EC2 instance
linux.
First, click, and you'll see
all these commands. ls block.
We're doing the
file check there.
Making the file system.
Automatically mount and
attach volume after reboot.
So all these steps are
going to exist for you.
You don't have to do this
off the top of your brain,
but here I'm just
showing it as an example.
So now that should
be good to go.
We can check to make sure that
got added by checking that file.
And we see there that our
line is added to this file
so that should be run
at launch, basically.
And so now let's check our
available storage again.
And we see that we have
our root volume there.
But also now we have our
976 megabyte or just about 1
gigabyte storage volume.
And so we can go to our
mounted volume here,
and we can-- so let's go
to just cd directly to it.
Let's go cd mount data/store.
And so that's-- we're in that
1 gigabyte my volume that we
created.
And then I'm going to create
a new file called file.txt.
My favorite file type name.
And we can just
add anything to it.
I don't know.
Sharad does storage.
There we go.
And then we'll do escape.
WQ.
Oops.
Ooh, this is something fun
I just forgot to do here.
So let's actually
back out for a second.
There we go.
So what I did, and I'm
going to probably pay
for this because it's
going to mess up now,
but because I'm on a file system
or I'm on a device, this EBS
volume, it's not--
technically, my base user
account Ubuntu at IP
whatever doesn't have
permissions to write to that.
So I have to do sudo
because this is kind
of outside my home directory.
Anything within my home
directory, anything
from like that, from that
tilde, from my home directory,
perfectly fine.
But if I'm on one of these kind
of deeper level file storage
systems, I will oftentimes be
required to do it this way.
And now I can go
in and say, Sharad
does storage better this time.
Now I should be able to save.
Yep.
And we can do cat
file.txt, and there it is.
Cool.
So now let's try one more thing.
Let's see if I regret
going this route.
I'll pause here for a second,
and then I'll come back to it.
OK.
Sorry about that.
I just wanted to make
sure I had my steps right
before I jumped
into something that
was going to be a
bit more involved,
and before I broke something.
So hopefully
everything goes well.
But either way, what
I want to try now
is creating a snapshot
of our EBS volume.
So this one we just created.
So what we're going
to do is we're going
to go back to the console here.
We're going to
click on our volume.
And then in the
actions menu, we are
going to click create snapshot.
Not surprising.
We can leave description
the same, but we'll do--
come down here, and
we'll say for the tag
name and my snapshot.
And we'll click create snapshot.
So we successfully
created snapshot.
If you need snapshot to
be immediately available,
consider using fast
snapshot restore.
We don't need it immediately
available, but we've--
will be good there.
And so now you can actually come
on this left hand menu again,
which if it's not showing
up, it's just under there.
And we click
snapshots this time,
and we see our
snapshot is created.
And so it's still in
the pending state,
which means it hasn't
been created yet.
It's actually doing it, right?
It's physically
copying the snapshot.
This is the-- again,
we're physically
taking a picture of what
our EBS volume on our device
looks like right now, right?
So it should have our
file that we saved.
That's what we're checking, is
to see if that file stays there.
And once it's done, it'll
change to a status of completed.
And let's see.
There you go.
But a cool thing
about this is only
used storage blocks
are copied to snapshot.
So any empty blocks of
storage that we have
don't occupy actual
storage space.
So it's actually really
efficient storage system here.
But now let's go
back to our terminal,
and we'll see that we
have our file in there.
What we're going to do is we're
going to remove that file.
We're going to delete it.
And again, because I'm
in a deeper file system
than I typically have
access to, I'm using sudo.
And so I'm removing that file.
And so now it does not
exist on my device--
on this actual EBS volume.
And we can see now
that we don't have it.
And so if we want
to recreate it,
right, let's say we accidentally
deleted a bunch of files.
We deleted the
folder, and we wanted
to back it up or restore
it from our snapshot.
We can now go and do
it this way, right?
So we go into the console.
We're going to
click my snapshot.
And so again, now it's
already completed.
It's available.
All that good stuff.
And then what we're going to
do is actually create a volume
from that snapshot.
So we go to actions, create
volume from snapshot.
So this is exactly
what it sounds
like is we're taking the
snapshot we created, making it
into a new volume and
unsurprisingly, we're
going to now try to mount that
new volume to our EC2 instance.
But the cool thing
is here again,
you see you can
increase the size of it.
So I could bump it up and
have more storage space
if I wanted to while
still having my files
that I created on there.
So it's another cool
feature of it, right?
A way to beef up your
storage capacity.
So we'll put our
availability zone back
to the correct
availability zone.
We'll come down here to
name, and we'll name it--
let's just do restored volume.
You could name it
anything you want,
but we'll call it
restored volume
because that's what it is.
We'll do create volume.
And now we should be able
to see it under our volumes.
So we'll go back to volumes.
Let's hit refresh.
Hmm.
I do not see it.
Oh, it's because I
have it filtered.
Duh.
There you go.
There is restored volume.
So restored volume.
It's all good in here.
And so now what we'll do
is we'll attach that volume
to our instance.
So let's go attach
volume instance.
We're going to go
to EBS lab demo.
And now you see it's
going to be under dev sdg.
We may see it under xvdg
just like we saw before,
but we'll attach volume now.
And then we can go back
once it's attached.
Let's make sure it's
looking like it's attached.
Yeah, it looks like it
should be roughly there.
Let's go to our terminal and--
oops.
Let's go to our terminal.
There we go.
And we are going to do
our same step, right?
We'll go back to
our home directory
just to be here and let's
do that ls block real quick.
And there you go.
So you see that xvdg.
So now we're going to do kind
of the same thing we did before
and mount the volume to this.
And actually, we can check--
we can use this command
from before to see
if it has a file system.
And so you see that
actually this time it
does have a file system, right?
It's got the ext3
because remember,
we created the original volume,
added a file system to it,
and then we created a snapshot.
So that file system was
stored with our volume.
So we can just skip
to-- ahead to the step
of making the directory.
So we'll make a directory
in the mount directory
that's called data-store2.
And then we can mount
our volume to that.
So we'll do sudo mount,
and we'll go dev xvdg
in mount data store--
oop, not stro, store2.
So let's ls over to that.
And we can see that
our file exists, right?
And we'll just cd2
too it as well--
2-- so you can mess with some
without having to type the file
path each time.
And so now, yeah, we can see
that file.txt exists there,
has our original content in it.
And by comparison,
if we went back
and went into just
the base data store,
it doesn't have it, right?
So that's the whole thing
is we've now created--
--or we created a volume,
mounted it or attached it,
mounted it, created
a file system on it,
created a directory,
added a file to it,
created a snapshot of that, then
went back in, deleted that file,
created a--
--from that created a
snapshot, created a new volume,
mounted that volume-- attached,
then mounted that volume.
And we can see now
that in there, we
have our original file.
And so if you then were
to do the same thing
and maybe pass off a
snapshot of your volume
to a user, which is another
way you could do this, right?
Let's say you have been
working on something and all
of a sudden, there's a new
employee at your company,
and they need access to the
same kind of files or data
that you have stored
on your computer.
Well, you could just create a
snapshot of your EBS volume.
They could create a new
volume from your snapshot
and mount it this way.
And now you've eased the burden
of transferring files and making
sure everything's set
in the right place.
You just have one
quick snapshot,
and you're ready to go.
So that's again, the
real power of using
these EBS volumes this way.
I hope this made some sense
and seemed somewhat practical
to you.
We'll again play around
with all these things more,
but leave it at that.
So we'll see you next time.
Bye.